what started out as a 9-1-1 call from an
elementary school 911
police we have we have a person with a
gun at the back of our cafeteria
cafeteria door trying to enter the
premises quickly turned into a violent
response by family members of students
six feet come on bro you know better
leave now i'm not going nowhere
it happened on august 12th in the
phoenix arizona suburb of el mirage when
a 9-1-1 call came in to area authorities
it's a report by our cafeteria manager
that a male with a gun was trying to
enter the cafeteria doors from our rear
entrance the caller told dispatch that a
suspicious person was seen outside
thompson ranch elementary school we're
in full lockdown we don't know it was
reported in the front office i'm in the
front office it was in our cafeteria
which is a distance more than 60
officers from multiple units responded
to the school within two minutes please
police police
police department first responders
checked the outside of the school where
the suspect was last seen and secured
the inside of the school as the
perimeter was set up around campus soon
after family members of students began
to arrive
i'm responsible for my little sister
brother
bro
22 year old victor castaneda was one of
the first to arrive saying he needed to
see his sister
we have officers inside everything's
safe here i need to know on my sister's
day bro
officials assured castaneda his sister
was safe and that the suspect had never
entered the school i can promise you he
didn't get into the campus i went out
the back he did not enter our campus did
you guys get them
in the school no alarms were set he is
not in the school castaneda then shook
hands with the school's vice principal
principal and a responding officer
officials then say 22-year-old jonathan
vincent davis was about to scale the
school's fence before officers stopped
him did i grab you did i come at you
after that davis began yelling that a
person with a gun was at the school
[Music]
you're not helping things right now
you're not trying to understand you're
getting your hands on you
am i touching you you're getting people
to panic
you need to back up
commotion then broke out as castaneda
got involved as officers pushed
castaneda to the ground a concealed
handgun fell from his waistband
officers yelled that a gun was present
and tased castaneda he was later
arrested davis soon began running toward
officers and then was tased
officials with the el mirage police
department say the incident is still
under investigation but that castaneda
was charged with weapons violations and
obstructing justice while davis was
charged with disorderly conduct
castaneda's mother 48 year old darlene
gonzalez was taken to a hospital and
treated for injuries sustained during
the event for the latest developments in
this story and all things true crime
stay with long crime network i'm sierra
gillespie